big big news here in los angeles it's
raining
when it rains in los angeles front page
news
i don't i haven't experienced the rain
myself right i live in a celebrity
bubble
right so i have not experienced rain
yeah
in like 28 years but my people tell me
that it's raining outside
yep i i haven't seen it either but
that's just because i
i live here now
i kind of picture you living here it's
not i mean look
is it the greatest existence to live in
an abandoned theater no
in hollywood no it's not the best but
it's not the worst it's not the worst
i've had worse
no it's funny earlier we went out to get
some coffee and it's across the street
and
as i said it's raining out so andy and i
went across the street we had our masks
on we were being safe
but we used uh audience members the
cardboard audience members to shield
ourselves from the rain
that's right so i want to thank uh i
think one guy is from st
louis i think there's a young lady uh
from baltimore
uh we want to thank neil young yeah rock
icon
and um that dog uh we want to thank the
dog also
they shielded us from the rain so we
thank you you're good fans
and you were good to help us out truly
supporting us truly supporting truly
supporting us
yes in the way that only a cardboard fan
can